so I saw this in the Daily Mail and I
know a lot of people get crazy when we
do stories from the Daily Mail but I
think every now and again they sort of
hit on something that's culturally
interesting they did a story on the rich
kids of Instagram basically these kids
that are worth millions sometimes
multi-million dollar real thing this is
a real thing real thing that's what I
couldn't quite tell it's like oh the
Daily Mail called the rich kids of
Instagram or is there like a group that
considers themselves the rich kids I
think from what I could tell I think
it's a little bit of both like they're
referring to themselves as the rich kids
of Instagram there was one of these
groups in Iran too and that one got shut
down by the government pretty quick so
let's look at a bunch of images these
are the rich kids of Instagram so titled
by themselves and by by the Daily Mail
and basically it's these kids that are
just SuperDuper rich and their kids
they're in their teens early 20s this is
not their money that they earned this is
money given to them by their parents and
they're in planes and in boats and
they're in exotic places and it looks
wads of cash Jimmy do you have those
kinds of $100 stacks 100 Ollie bills on
your gold under your gold watch and
they're in these crazy hot tubs and
pools and I thought this story was
interesting because we all see this
every time you go on Instagram you see
someone's food looks better than yours
every time they're at a beach because of
the filters it looks better than the
beach that you're at and we're all
making ourselves kind of crazy but I
think there's something particularly
kind of gross about it being kids that
didn't earn the money on earned
confidence is repulsive horribly really
is repulsive it's okay to be wealthy
like you don't have to be ashamed of
inheriting your parents money little
[ __ ] you don't be but not enough to not
take it what did how did you say
unearned what unearned confidence oh
it's so that's why we don't like real
crust hurt so much yes yes that's right
that's right thanks people like just be
appreciative like you know so go on
Instagram and do what everybody else
does and show a picture of you with your
friends Instagram there's too many
photos of ourselves no kidding
there's just it's a it has its its its
that's a like we did a story earlier
that'll be up on the ruble report about
the legacy contacts on Facebook and and
Jimmy made a great point like you're
dead it doesn't nothing matters it
doesn't and you know there was a way
that we were able to inform people that
you were dead before Facebook
pretty sure we can go back right it gets
out you know so and not everybody needs
to know right away that I died it's okay
yeah like you know people will be live
people find out in nine months I been
didn't come on he did all that's that's
a shame
let's have a drink to him that would be
nice that's okay yeah that's all I
require people have to go on with their
lives so this it's just embarrassing to
look at these kids it's embarrassing and
they don't know it
they have george w bush's unearned
confidence and it's a the under comes i
got a quote here from one of the girls
that does this stuff that posts all this
stuff it's really thought it goes
exactly to what you're saying she says I
don't think I should be judged for
posting a photo like eating caviar at
Claridge's in London while it's okay for
someone to post a picture at McDonald's
so she's saying well I'm just doing the
same [ __ ] I just happen to have more
money so I'm doing it nicer no that was
what's what's called being out of touch
yeah yeah what she just said just
understand what the problem is yeah
because she's out of touch she's that
person so badly needs therapy like they
might be able to be she could be a
functioning normal person of course
there's a difference yeah but by the way
who cares about you with a picture of
McDonald's by the way but right
necessary yeah I mean go to McDonald's
is fine nobody needs a photo I'm pretty
sure that the French fries at McDonald's
are probably better than the French
fries at Claridge's I know that Claire
doesn't even know what any have yard
Claridge's you know the expression about
that they used for george w bush now who
said it first but and maybe it's a
hundred years old or as oldest baseball
but it's the best expression there is
you know these kids were born on third
base and think they had a triple yes
that you can't put it any better I think
he was a I said that are in Richards it
was either you were and Richard said
that and then she also said poor George
boys born with a silver foot as well
exactly
well that's they're both good and that
does sound like a enriches the boy do
you agree with Ben's point they have we
ever been more vain than we are now as a
society because no selfie sticks also I
think we're just as vain we just now
have an outlet probably which is I think
it actually makes us Vayner it makes us
all constantly thinking about how we
look and appear and you know they've
done studies they figured out that
people who'd spend the more time you
spend on social media the more depressed
you are and the reason is that they
posit I agree with it is that people
don't post their failures people only
post when they're winning look
Hey look I got invited to a comedy
festival in Hawaii hey look I'm doing a
new movie I'm on a set Hey look at I
just want a million dollars in Vegas oh
hey look I'm doing it so nobody ever
goes there hey I woke up today wanting
to kill myself again there's a picture
know one of the best one of my best
attributes Jay is that is that I'm a bad
self promoter like and and there's
something there's a quality to that that
I'm uncomfortable promoting yes right
and now on Twitter
that's what about Twitter so I don't
really go on Facebook I don't know on
Instagram it's just Twitter and mostly
what I do on Twitter's Reid get
information articles people sent so I
think I use Twitter for the right way
but that said you're supposed to go on
to what are you supposed to promote
yourself you're supposed to be and and
and now I'm getting more comfortable
with it and it sucks it's a bet it is
taken away a quality of mine that now
I'm a little more comfortable talking
about how great I am and I'm not that
great I'm just like everybody else yeah
and I hear you on that and I look I'm a
big Twitter or Twitter all the time and
I try to keep people entertained while
also promoting life but also there there
is some you're trying to entertain a
once in a blue moon everybody so much we
speed back into that I'll look again uh
but but there is a difference for the
way we have to use it right the way we
have to use this stuff probably but yeah
sort of it's part of what we've got if
you were doing all your gigs and just
wasn't on Facebook - it would be yes so
no you have to do it and by the way I
just now instead of me blocking people I
try to get them to block me oh you
believe so yesterday I went out and
there was a comedian in the Midwest and
he putted a picture of him he has a
picture of himself with Victoria Jackson
from Santa Night Live he made a big
thing but she's crazy
right so he made a thing about how she
was they didn't want her on the show the
40 year anniversary and she had a they
she had to sit in a room by herself
sounds like she got her own dressing
room and he said it was because she was
a conservative Christian and and I kept
preg notes because she's [ __ ] batshit
crazy
and says a lot of hateful stuff about
people and I would link to an article
the twenty worst things that Victoria
Jackson had ever said and he would
immediately delete it and I immediately
put it back up and he would immediately
and I started putting on other posts on
his page and putting it everywhere
finally he blocked me we need more to do
with your daily activities all right
what do you think's worse the rich kids
of Instagram or the poor average people
of Twitter let us know in the comments
right